ich darf mich bedanken für 23 tolle
jahre
es war eine tolle zeit viele nette
menschen kennengelernt und
fraktionsübergreifend viele werde ich
vom bisschen sogar frau frieda wäre für
rede habe ich überlegt ob es meine
situation gab wo wir zwei politisch
einer meinung waren ich kann mich im
moment nicht daran erinnern
menschlich ist claudia roth eine granate
und sie ist kompetent sie an ahnung vom
fußball
und da spielen sie in einer liga mit dem
fischer franz josef jung und anderen und
wir nehmen uns eigentlich seit 20 jahren
vor mal ein spiel köln ging aufgrund zu
besuchen vielleicht schaffen wir das und
am ende nach dem schluss wird größte ich
auch die vizepräsidentin des deutschen
bundestages über das vermutete ergebnis
hinweg
ich sage das fraktionsübergreifend tolle
menschen kennengelernt
ich weiß nicht ob ich meine karriere
ruinieren wenn ich sage es war ein
vergnügen mit dir zusammen zu arbeiten
und euch allen wünsche ich für die zeit
bekommt bei aller härte der
auseinandersetzung im wahlkampf geht
immer ordentlich miteinander rum
danke wolfgang bosbach am ende brach ihm
ein wenig die stimme seine abschiedsrede
hier er hört auf er wird nicht wieder
antreten in der nächsten
legislaturperiode ein profilierter in
politiker hier im haus und ein bekannter
gast in talkshows und am radio
[Applaus]